i actually sat down
with will and had a conversation he gave
me his blessing
after august alcena claimed he had a
relationship with will smith's
wife jada pinkett smith the smiths were
silent
but not anymore with jada making a major
statement on social media on thursday
the 48 year old actress hit up twitter
writing there's some healing that needs
to happen
so i'm bringing myself to the red table
it seems safe to assume that that tweet
was about the august drama
and of course the red table is a
reference to jada's facebook watch talk
show
red table talk well the red table is a
place of testimony
august has actually been a guest on the
show before
and then we got all cute who
my mother's 64 august 25 yes
and he is at the beginning stages yes
of a clean life now it's unclear when
jada will be addressing the topic on her
show
but new episodes typically drop on
fridays
romance rumors between august and jada
have circulated for a while
and in 2019 fans speculated that the
musician's song nanya was
written about the 48 year old actress
[Music]
at the time august denied those claims
people don't necessarily know the truth
but i've never
done anything wrong but during a recent
interview with angela yee
about his new album the project 2 state
of emergency
the 27 year old singer claimed he's lost
money friendships and
relationships over the rumors people
can have whatever ideas that they like
but
what i'm not okay with is uh my
character
you know being in question i'm not a
troublemaker
i don't like drama and i also don't
think that
it's ever important for people to know
what i do who i sleep with
who i date right but uh in this instance
it's very different because as i said
there's so many people that are
side-eyeing me looking at me
questionable
about it that's when he claimed jadah's
husband of 22 years
actually gave him permission to move
forward with jada
i actually sat down with
will and had a conversation due to the
transformation from their marriage to
life partnership that they've spoken on
several times
and it you know not involving
romanticism
he gave me his blessing will and jada
have long been rumored to have an
open marriage something they've denied
but they have admitted
to having a non-traditional marriage
opting to call each other
life partners rather than husband or
wife
in fact last year jada revealed that
they don't celebrate their wedding
anniversary
it's more of a life partnership yeah so
it's not steeped
in narrative day in that day yeah so
there's no
like we don't really celebrate that day
you know what i'm saying yeah anymore in
that sense because
the context of our union is
totally different yeah and in 2018 will
opened up about his marriage
during an interview with titles rap
radar podcast
we refer to ourselves as life partners
right where you get into that space when
you realize
you are literally with somebody for the
rest of your life
there's no deal breakers there's nothing
she could do
ever nothing that would break
our relationship she has my
support till death